il aurait dû être immergé dans l'eau ils
sont aujourd'hui soigneusement rangés
sur le pont du bateau file et casiers ou
encore ciré tout ce matériel ne devrait
pas revoir la mer avant un moment
face au confinement et dix pêcheurs
depuis 20 ans a décidé de rester à quai
au prix du poisson ce n'est pas rentable
de ses pas rentable d'aller travailler
au premier compliment on a perdu 50
entre 40 et 50% de la valeur du poisson
là le deuxième confinement on a il ya
certaines espèces qui se maintiennent
parce qu'il n'a pas énormément de pêcher
mais sur les espèces qui sont le plus
pêché
on peut perdre jusqu'à 60-70 version du
prix tous les beaux poissons
principalement pour la restauration du
fait que c'est fermé
on n'a pas de on vend le poisson que les
meilleurs achats de boissons games est
très très bien pris un prix qui a chuté
de manière vertigineuse depuis l'année
dernière en 2019 le kilo de bar se
vendait 15 euros cette année seulement 5
euros
jean-marie pêcheurs depuis 20 ans à
fécamp tente de garder un semblant
d'activité
l'avenir lui semble pourtant bien
incertain pour lui les aides du
gouvernement sont insuffisantes face aux
difficultés rencontrées
alors je sais pas trop si on va repartir
ou pas ce pas facile pour nous le
gouvernement nous promet monts et
merveilles
ce qui n'est pas le cas si vous n'avez
pas de fermeture administrative
vous n'avez pas grand chose pourtant on
est soumis
l'impact du coc vide les cours est en
mauvais les restaurants fermés les ya
pas deux il ya pas de cours dans le
poisson quoi aux conséquences de la
crise sanitaire vient s'ajouter la
question du breakbeat les acteurs du
secteur sont formels si l'interdiction
de travailler dans les eaux britanniques
et mise en vigueur la pêche française ne
s'en remettra pas et pour cause leur
bateau comme ceux de la belgique ou
encore des pays bas pourrait alors se
rabattre sur les eaux hexagonal une
issue dramatique pour les ressources
maritimes déjà menacée par la pêche
intensive